si son 314 los no son 117 se aprueba el
proyecto de ley
con esos resultados el proyecto para la
suspensión del techo de la deuda superó
la revisión en la cámara de
representantes continuando así con el
trámite en el congreso de la iniciativa
del presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden y el líder republicano de la
cámara baja Kevin mccarthy la resolución
fue celebrada desde la Casa Blanca
esta noche la cámara dio un paso
fundamental para evitar un
incumplimiento de pago por primera vez y
proteger la histórica recuperación
económica de nuestro país ganada con
tanto esfuerzo este acuerdo
presupuestario es un compromiso
bipartidista por su parte el republicano
mccarthy quien ha quedado en el ojo de
las críticas de miembros de su propio
partido por los términos del acuerdo
también se mostró conforme con la
decisión de la cámara baja
history esta noche Todos hemos hecho
historia porque este es el mayor recorte
y Ahorro que este congreso ha votado
nunca Y no es que solo lo votemos Esto
va a ser ley
ahora el proyecto pasará la próxima
instancia el senado el presidente pidió
a la cámara alta que lo apruebe lo antes
posible ante los avisos de que el debate
podría extenderse durante el fin de
semana dominado estrechamente por los
demócratas el senado deberá debatir y
sancionar favorablemente la iniciativa
para llevarla al escritorio del
presidente para ser sancionada antes del
próximo lunes 5 de junio